hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the power of multiplexing
luminex technology presented by dr.
David Gordon PhD we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by Latin roots and sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about Thermo Fisher Scientific
please visit www.isminc.com of a 50,000
employees in 50 countries our mission is
to enable our customers to make the
world healthier cleaner and safer we
help our customers accelerate life
sciences research solve complex
analytical challenges and patient
diagnostics and increased laboratory
productivity through our premier brands
thermo scientific applied Biosystems in
vitro Jenn Fisher scientific and unity
lab services we offer an unmatched
combination of innovative technologies
purchasing convenience and comprehensive
support I'm Brendan Kelly Kim and I'll
be a moderator for this event before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll try to
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of dr. Gordon's
presentation also please notice we'll be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge this window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right finally if you have any trouble
hearing or seeing this presentation
properly please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button lower left to let us know that
you're having a problem I'd now like to
introduce our speaker dr. David Borden
David received
PhD and postdoctoral work focused on the
study of g-protein coupled receptor
pharmacology and pharmacist following
his academic training
he led Luminex based multiplex
immunoassay platform development efforts
at a luminance partnering company in
2009 David joints are most assurance is
working on the development of novel
immunoassays platforms proto Plex immune
response sa working on next-gen
immunoassay technologies
David is interested in working with
translational investigators he opinion
leaders to identify serum based
biomarkers in cancer autoimmunity and
inflammation beyond his research and
development responsibilities David is
dedicated to platform strategy in the
antibody content roadmap I will now turn
the presentation over to David
thank you very much Brenda hey everyone
it's great to meet you all thank you
very much for joining our lab roots
event today so as I was introduced I
lead an armed team R&D team here in
Carlsbad California focusing on
next-generation amino acids as well as
as well as expanding our luminex
basement platform today I'd like to give
more of an introduction introduction to
the luminix technology even though the
technology has been out for a number of
years there's quite a few people who are
not as familiar with the technology and
they have yet to take the full advantage
of the power of multiplexing how it can
really save you time money and give you
higher quality data so let's get started
so first of all I'll admit from my my
doctoral work and thereafter I really am
a proteomics person I really do
appreciate the power of the whole genome
sequencing efforts have uncovered but
really a lot of I think you'll see in
the next coming decades a lot of the
proteomic space
oncology so this slide just kind of
overviews or highlights you know post
human genome project work you know
there's at least 20,000 proteins that
have been identified and of course that
number keeps getting larger the post
translational modifications and all
sorts of subtle differences in protein
modifications simulation phosphorylation
etc really can make a difference and so
this schematic on the right side it's
just to remind everyone that you know
when you're talking about let's say a
kinase signaling pathway there's a lot
of different knobs that can be turned by
our own immune system our own cell
biology regulatory systems in our body
and this this it's very close home close
to home for me because for example my
postdoctoral work is really
focused on on gpcr city and you know I
joke with my colleagues that if I had a
dollar for every time I ran a Western
blot or wanted to look at protein
modifications in signaling pathways if I
had a buck for every time I had to do
that in a single Plex approach I'd be a
rich man and multiplex technology really
helps interrogate a number of different
protein pathways in one single
experiment and long story short I wish
I'd had the type of technology I'm going
to talk about today I wish I had had it
at my disposal when I was a postdoc it
definitely would have shaved some some
years off so all joking aside you know
there's a lot of exciting work in the
proteomics space and so I want to move
on to here is really to talk about the
key areas I'm on slide three the key
areas that are technologies focus on and
this is not all-inclusive but some key
areas where we really are covering the
space well are in the areas inflammation
autoimmunity and as many know from the
seminal work from Hanahan and Weinberg
original paper came out and fell in 2001
where an and Weinberg spoke of all of
the different processes that are
involved in the propagation of cancer
and this would you article that I'm
citing here at the bottom actually gives
a very nice update in 2011 of what has
been addressed in the last decade and
where do we still have to go and it's a
very great read for those of you who but
it really does outline how challenging
cancer is to study treat from the
translational investigator perspective
and it's also it's very exciting for us
in the biomedical research space
especially us in the the tool provider
space because my job and the job of our
team is basically to provide
next tools for investigators such as
yourself and so we really do our our
sign of success is is developing high
quality tools that are second to none
that allow you to make great discoveries
so we're very excited about this work I
think as a community there's a lot of
work yet to be done but we're in on the
on the right track
and so this wire diagram of the immune
system basically it's meant to show and
I apologize if it's too small to read
but the point here is that the immune
system our immune system is very complex
and we know that a single cytokine does
not have a single you know a plus B
equals C responsibility there are a
number of cytokines that play roles in a
number of different steps in the
pathways everything from let's say
activating a b-cell to having maybe
t-cell function as well and so being
able to make sense of changes in
inflammatory cytokines for example can
be quite a challenge especially if you
were to do that on a target like target
basis and so the technologies that I'm
going to talk about today oh wow one to
take a single sample let's say a human
serum sample or a cell culture
supernatant and measure a number of
targets in one shot and I'll go over the
reasons why you'd want to do that in
just a moment but you can imagine the
type of work that is required to make
these kinds of conclusions that are
highlighted in his wire diagram for
example and by the way I just thought to
mention earlier that we will be pushing
out poll questions throughout this
presentation and please feel free to
quickly a select on response I will try
not to make it too distracting but I
think it's it's great to get feedback
from experienced users such as yourself
as to your answers help us make better
products so thank you very much for that
participation so you know as far as
creating clarity out of this chaos
you know I use chaos in a positive light
there's a lot going on on our immune
systems as we know like I mentioned a
therapeutic monoclonal antibodies are
becoming a gold standard for a lot of
treatment diseases in fact last year I
attended the American Society of
Clinical Oncology meeting in Chicago and
and it just amazed me the number of
companies that they're one of their
chief pipelines or their primary
pipelines in the drug development
process are all therapeutic and as
anyone who has seen the commercials
you'll see a drug like Humera initially
comes out for treatment there's one
disease and now they're realizing that
you know what therapeutic monoclonal
antibody against TNF alpha can treat a
lot of different inflammatory conditions
so it just shows the vast breadth of
coverage is that being able to regulate
these inflammatory moderators can have
on our health and our ability to combat
disease but being able to create clarity
on that chaos and in other words for us
to develop tools that really provide the
best toolbox for you it all starts with
antibodies and what I've highlighted in
this slide is basically just to remind
everyone the the assays that we
developed they're only as good as the
antibodies I speak very candidly about
this because as a tool developer for a
number of years in fact prior to our
integration and just for a little
history I started with the in be Trojan
company which eventually became Life
Technologies and then through our merger
became Thermo Fisher Scientific in the
years prior to joining thermo Fisher it
was quite frustrating to not have enough
good high-quality antibodies at my
convenience or at my use and so I wanted
to build new acid platforms but with
limited antibodies I really felt my
hands were tied and so
since the combined the new Thermo Fisher
Scientific organization you know I
highlight fear that we have over 40,000
antibodies and that number keeps growing
and I'm actually involved in our
antibody roadmap initiative as well and
it's very exciting to see our work on on
developing new antibodies to exciting
targets I work with a very great team of
antibody sensors were who are working
out with Kia commune leaders to develop
these these best antibodies for of new
targets so again high quality kits and
systems all start with high quality
antibodies of course we're going after
the most relevant targets for example
cytokines chemokines signaling proteins
but then also we want to be able to
measure very low amounts of these
proteins and all sorts of biological
fluids serum plasma and in fact you know
it's very interesting we even have
people coming to us that are studying
for example dry eye disease or other
challenging diseases where sample volume
is very limited and I'll get into that
just a minute that's another reason why
you would want to conduct as many
measurements in single well as possible
because some of the investigators may
only have twenty or thirty microliters
or in some cases only five microliters
so they want to be able get as much data
out of that single reading as possible
so it's very important to be very very
customer centric and make sure that
we're listening to the end user and what
they need and so one of my focus areas
since joining the organization has been
biomarkers biomarker discovery and
validation the term is used a lot but I
think it's really important to
understand that biomarker identification
is not a single measurement it's an
entire process and I've worked with a
lot of great scientists
currently and in the past they had
taught me this this biomarker space and
it's important to note here that you
know beyond studying the mechanism of a
disease biomarkers are really important
to understand a disease progression so
not only how a disease may start but
also to understand what to work for when
a disease may be is getting better or
worse and that's where translational
investigators are very interested in the
amount of circulating markers in for
example cancer it's important to note I
only mentioned this once did you know
the products I'm gonna be talking about
today our research is only by for
example I do have clinical investigators
that I work with which we're we're
taking these very disease relevant
samples and and better understanding
various levels of analytes and diseases
such as bone marrow or bone or
transplantation for example for blood
cancers as well as rheumatoid arthritis
and other the reason biomarker discovery
is so important is because as you can
imagine the samples from all sorts of
individuals or even cell cultural
populations they're very different
not everything behaves the same way and
that's why biomarker discovery is so
important because about a good biomarker
needs to be able to be a protein or
analyte that is known to be upregulated
or over expressed a cross across a wide
population and we're all show in just a
minute is sort of a three-step process
to discover verify and validate it's
very important to note that a good
biomarker can withstand or or survives
the identification process and is robust
enough to still be a identified
but this is one area where I think we
really do set ourselves apart that we
take great pride and understanding this
workflow and being able to know how to
use the right tool at the right time and
that's something I gave a talk at the
American associated association of
immunologist
last year and it was on a general
protein Quan workflows and the take-home
message from that talk was we have a lot
of tools to use for protein after
another scientific what sets us apart is
knowing when to advise to a customer
Wendy used by tool for example when we'd
use flow cytometry versus Western bloc
or why would you use the multiplex
immunoassay versus Eliza or Western one
it's very important to know why and be
able to provide that guidance to the
end-user so this is the biomarker
discovery validation workflow always
just from fire engines so it's a three
step process and basically if you look
at this XY coordinate here on the y axis
we have a number of targets so imagine
this is from zero to let's say I don't
know 20,000 the whole program or larger
and then this is the number of samples
you would test for a given a say so a
discovery platform or a discovery tool
is one that allows you to potentially
identify hundreds or thousands of
targets because of the platform he's for
now and I'll get to this in the next
slide but you can imagine that tools
like let's say mass spec you're not
going to perform mass spec on thousands
of samples just because the way the
workflows currently laid out however
mass spec on the other hand can
interrogate the entire podium looking
for unique proteins that are maybe over
abundant on their hand when you move
from discovery to verification what you
want to do is you want to use a platform
that you can test a larger number of
samples but maybe the total number of
proteins that can measure there's a
little more limited so you're basically
I've seen a wide net and discovery and
then going to something a little more
limited and verification and then
finally invalidation what you want is a
platform that allows you to test
thousands of samples and this really
it's the point of statistical or
clinical relevance so good platform may
be something that can only measure let's
say one two or three analytes but it's
something that you can perform in high
throughput or ultra high def a great
example of these three platforms would
be for example orbitrap world leader in
this technology and so this is a
technology that allows you to truly
interrogate the entire material once an
investigator has basically narrowed down
or the potential possibilities from
let's say thousands of proteins down to
maybe 30 or 50 that's when you would use
a bead based platform which is the heart
of today's talk it uses a B based
platform that you can measure them
number and then finally once you distill
this down even further one might use a
single Plex technology like Eliza by the
way and so it's whether you're doing
discovery verification or validation you
use the right tool at the right time
otherwise you'll be wasting time money
resources
unfortunately we cover all three now
this is one area that I think in the
future a lot of people are looking to
develop next-gen technologies that allow
you to perform an immunoassay
and that would be another great talking
future so as far as focusing more on the
last two verification validation you
know whether somebody performs a Western
blot simplex Allies or a multiplex T you
know massive it depends on a couple of
different needs for example what
sensitivity do they do they really need
the sensitivity or are they just looking
for a qualitative measure
the antibody menu now now that we have a
much larger menu that's less of concern
but definitely you know sometimes we
only have a particular target and let's
say a Western blot primary antibody and
not a complete gleizes
so one night performed Western blotting
throwing up a quick answer throughput
now everyone knows that
for example performing Western blotting
on hundreds or thousands of samples can
be quite laborious whereas maybe
performing a single X Eliza can get the
same answer with much less headache and
there might be other considerations to
you know a certain user may actually be
wanting to confirm the size of the
protein cell localization so maybe
they're trying to separate organelle
structures and work at whether or not a
particular protein is is totalized with
another protein so IP might be important
in that case you know precipitation so
anyway again using the right tool that
my time is very important and so let's
dig deep in or dive deep now into
multiplex but I'll start out by sitting
up this example here we all know
sandwich Eliza's the way they work you
have a capture antibody typically a
monoclonal antibody immobilized on plate
surface you capture the analyte of
interest maybe some in serum and then
you'll come in with a after you know
multiple washes you'll incubate with a
another Anna boy against the same
protein and in some cases you might even
use a secondary antibody um you can see
there's a number of steps here and of
course for the analytes dependent
measure we have to have each capture
antibody on a different plate because
there really is no way to distinguish
the reporter signal that originated from
capturing one analyte versus the other
so of course people separate their
eliza's based upon the capture molecule
capture
now again it becomes a little more
challenging if somebody wants to look at
a number of an lines imagine this
situation where somebody wants to look
at let's say not 4 but 16 different
anilines well that's a lot of plates and
you can imagine wouldn't it be nice if
you could compress all that all that
analytical power into a single plate and
that's where we are going with luminex
technology and so again here's the
traditional Aliza and so luminex
Corporation a company that it started in
Austin Texas and their core intellectual
property is around the ability to
manufacture these six micron polystyrene
beads what makes these beads special is
that the beads are dyed or colored with
a ratio of infrared and that dies so
what we're saying here just for example
is an eight by eight so eight different
concentrations I move that down eight
concentrations of it and you can imagine
that this is for example Merlot
this is high high what this ratio metric
combination of these two guys allows one
to do is to be able to identify which
bead is which these are fluorescent dyes
so you can imagine excitation the
emission spectra given off by this speed
here it's a very different readout than
this bead here and so what that allows
you to do is to basically utilize
different solid phases for a iliza like
technology but now on a beat and so
here's again the same eight by eight
example but let's now pretend that in
this case and these this is the way our
case behaved one would conjugate an anti
Isleton antibody on this beat region and
they're called bead regions to basically
identify each one is a unique beet color
so in isolation we conjugate this bead
region to
tae-il tear antibody this one to read
file for gm-csf and TNF alpha for
example and these beans are these six
micron polystyrene beads have about 3
million binding sites so it's not just a
single antibody it's many many and what
happens here is now you've got in this
case we have four different bead regions
each conjugated with their own analyte
specific antibody but now what we can do
is we can combine these beads in a
single well and because each antibody
each bead is conjugated with a very high
quality antibody that's very specific
for a particular analyte the aisle to
bead only binds aisle to aisle for bead
only binds aisle for etcetera so after a
wash event
so first the beats are combined then the
actor like for example human serum we
capture the analyte specific events with
four beats and then you wash the beads
and then come in with another set of
antibodies a cocktail of detection and
all these detection antibodies again are
specific for the particular analyte of
interest but what's unique about these
antibodies is they're already pre
conjugated with a fluorophore cycle you
read them and this floor floor is in
common so basically this is the reporter
signal so imagine here each one of these
beads is identified by its fluorescent
readout for association with a
particular analyte and then the reporter
readout is proportional to the amount of
binding that occurs on the surface of
the bead so what you can see here is
that larger reporter signal equals
larger number so again the RPE
quantitate the binding events in the
bead region identifies which particular
analyte and there are two types of
instrumentations
in two different types of core
technologies that luminex uses to
identify the beads and
order one is a flow cell based system
which some of you in the lab might have
seen in lx100 or to instrumental x-pac
3d the other more recently released
instrument is basically a planar flow so
what happens is the beads under the
floor cell a magnet pulls them down to
create a mono air so now you're actually
exciting and measuring the admission of
the beads for the red signal which of
course gets you for example like a
microarray layout of all the beads and
then the green laser comes in and
identifies so similar concept just is a
different way of looking at it so in the
end what this technology allows you to
do is just for the sake of our initial
example of looking at these four
analytes this is the way you would have
to measure these single analytes usually
nowise but now this is what you can do
with Luminex based technology and single
well you can measure all four and this
is just for simplification of the
example but you can imagine here we have
about anywhere from three to four
thousand beads per well for each and so
what you can imagine here is there are
many you know for example thousands of
bead of bead number one thousands of
bead for bead number two etc etc so not
only are you able through measure each
of the four analytes in this example in
one realm you're measuring a lot of
different binding events where as an
analyzer you're looking at a single
readout a single snapshot and so the way
the instrumentation works for luminance
is each bead and this was kind of
highlighted here each beat comes down
the flow cell sequentially and gets
interrogated by both forms of light with
a laser or LEDs but there are many many
points or many events measured in the
next base pop platform versus analyzed
and on the right hand side here I've
just very quickly laid out the workflow
in terms of starting with the antibody
coated beads all the way through
requiring the data and by the way this
slide deck as well as our white white
papers and other brochures that
highlight this in greater detail so a
great example of why or the power of
this is for example with a k2 we have an
87 flex that allows Warren to measure
seven different targets involved in
making signaling simultaneously so you
can imagine here that and this is this
kind of brings me back memories of my
postdoc where you know I might have been
looking at a phosphorylation pathway but
looking at it one protein at a time and
if that one Western blot didn't work or
I identified wait okay it's not that
protein that's involved in this
particular pathway I would then have to
go back and try another protein
candidate
whereas with multiplexing you can cast a
wider net and cover a lot of bases in
this answer and so this next image here
really does highlight one of our newest
launches and that is the cytokine human
35 plus and this is just an example of
the wealth of data so this is across
eight different samples one through
eight and then looking at all of the
different cytokine profiles for those
eight samples so just it's kind of a
nice snapshot of where some targets and
honestly this this graphic here it's
kind of hard to see very subtle changes
of these other lower bars but you can
imagine that certain targets are
significantly different in certain
samples and others are basically at
basil or constitutive levels and don't
change at all so again that you know
they're one of the highlights of the
power of multiplexing is reduced cost
per data point
reduced labor time reduce sample usage
again 35 different analytes measured in
a single well and this is
from a 25 migrator serum sample increase
in like analyte reduced and like that
variability again if one was to measure
all of these 35 different analytes in
isolation somebody would have to go back
and put all that data together and make
sure that all the controls match up and
now I've heard of people trying to
normalize data from dozens of different
Eliza's and you can imagine if in one
particular readout they add a little
more sample than the other it just
creates a lot of headache and all of
that headache is and then finally the
amount of data you get per sample again
I mentioned some people that are looking
at human tear samples or are very small
maybe a case of a mouse cytokine study
we all know the terminal bleed from the
house is a very small bomb and so one
can imagine that they want to get as
much high quality data out of a single
sample and then finally this insect just
provides a nice summary of the cost per
data point and it's kind of hard to read
here but the cost per data point for
Eliza's is in the blue here and then I
just outlined in red the cost for the
analytes so it's a much more cost
effective approach than Eliza's every
time but again it's about using the
right tool at the right time if one has
gotten to the point where they have
narrowed their bottom markers down to
just one or two targets
Eliza's or another single plex
technology is perfectly practical it's
well suited however somebody is still in
bed and that targeted I call it targeted
discovery they don't have a higher plex
Orbitrap technology at their disposal
even a 35 plus in solution could be
considered a more limited discovery or
verification study so if they're at that
point in their workflow they definitely
need
so this is just a great example and by
the way again I mentioned this is from
one of our white papers we have these
white papers available for you to
download after this talk this is just a
great example of the great precision and
this is from our human at different kind
fourteen plus and so this is plate one
in red complete two in gray for a number
of different analytes here I'm you can
see the plate to plate variation very
very so this is again another reason why
it is important to focus on be based the
next assays for this discovery work
because that plate to plate you asked
are inter and intra assay variation we
want to minimize that is not just
possible and is performed very well this
is another slide from that white paper
just demonstrating the dynamic range as
well as the concordance on the left-hand
side here this is the dynamic range for
a particular target looking at it with
the luminex assay here in blue I just
highlighted it and then this green line
over here is basically a more limited
dynamic range of corresponding Aliza and
the importance of dynamic range is of
course fewer sampling solutions are
required and fewer repeats I think for
anybody that's working with you know sa
space sometimes you've run some samples
and they're either typically they're too
concentrated if they're too dilute some
people will try to concentrate the
sample but that's where if the samples
to do it that's where having a very high
sensitivity asset so in the future be
talking about aspects of this dynamic
range it's really important to not have
to repeat assays because
sampling to concentrate and in case but
Eliza sometimes the sample will be out
here somewhere and it's too concentrated
to be read on the platen so that's for
the next technology because it can be
very helpful secondly concordance a lot
of people that will be switching from
our Eliza parts orange to a luminex
platform it's important for them to know
that I measure that that they look on
the Eliza platform compares or Conchords
well with arguing that's possible
and this is just a great example of an
analyte where we're looking at it on the
y-axis using the Eliza platform and on
the x-axis and the concordance is a nice
R square a very high r-squared value so
it actually come towards and what that
does for the people is that it allows us
to transition to the next technology it
also is nice to compare data sense I
think I talked to a lot of people that
had values different technologies before
and sometimes there's a multiplication
factor and they basically have to sort
of transform the data from one platform
to the other in order to compare it and
and that always makes me a little
apprehensive because it means that
there's something fundamentally
different in the asset that is possibly
measuring something different in our
case we see concordance between also
it's great for cross-site collaborations
we want people to feel comfortable to
share data with different individuals
depend upon so this next slide was
really just to give you a couple of
quick examples of how our customers have
used our technology to benefit their
work a lot of you may know of this study
this was the classic TGN 1412 trial
study over a decade ago there was a
small bio pharma company in the UK that
was developing
a therapeutic monoclonal antibody
against cd28 it was considered a t-cell
specific antibody and it lacked a co
stimulatory requirement and B the
antibody was developed to target
autoimmunity and chronic lymphocytic
leukemia it was designed to bind cd28
and release anti-inflammatory cytokines
and expand T regs
Windus this therapeutic Malfoy I have
body went to clinical trials there were
adverse events people were harmed from
and with it was quickly taken off the
market well this group here this group
actually our customer this was not a
group that developed the antibody this
was the group that actually did a
retrospective study and this was
published in in 2010 but they basically
went back and tried to better understand
what happened what possibly could have
led to these adverse events so what they
did is they used our 30 Plex in features
in human cytokine panel in a monocyte
culture system where they added the TGN
1412 or the cd28 anti cd28 and then
measured a number of different Pro
regulatory cytokines and chemokines and
what they found was that upon edition of
the TGN 1412 or the cd28 antibody the
basically caused recruitment of
monocytes to the vascular endothelium
which then caused a release of a number
of inflammatory cytokines and most
importantly recruitment of natural
killer cells and so over the years we've
seen the term cytokine storm used in a
variety of different contexts and this
is a great example of how it's believed
now that this therapeutic monoclonal
antibody is actually doing a lot more
than division and so this is just a
great example i'm not saying that this
could have prevented
what happened but it was a great example
of how we can learn from particular
situations and I think now a lot of
people are doing this type of multi
target examination in our proactive
manner to really understand the system
before it moves on in these trials and
you can imagine this would have been
very difficult work to perform on a
single Plex target by target basis okay
this next study this is near and dear to
my heart just because of my interest in
systems biology and a high content
screening this study was this
interdisciplinary group that used our
twenty five-plus cycle to understand so
CLO many know is is a combined diseases
disease that is believed to start as an
inflammatory response and so what this
group of authors did is they've looked
at 84 CLL patients and 49 h-net controls
what they did is they also knew of the
patient populations and how severe their
form of CLL is and they scored severity
of the disease as either their partner
their outcome was was sort of
abbreviated as good or poor so an
individual therapy in less than five
years after being diagnosed with CLL
we're giving a poor outcome that
dendogram here is basically indicated by
the black boxes so these are individuals
that had a more severe form of the
disease the the individuals that had a
less severe form of the disease or a
good prognosis where individuals that
did not have to receive treatment until
greater than five years after initial
diagnosis and those individuals are
highlighted in the future and then
healthy age match controls are indicated
and again let me just remind everyone
again the our assays are only for
researchers only this is not used for
any clinical diagnosis but it's very
insightful and very informative to
understand how these disease relevant
samples have varying levels of these
cytokines so the authors did is they
took all of these these human serum
samples and they looked at the 25
different cytokines and what they found
was varying levels of about seven or
eight different cytokines and what we
see here is that they clustered the
cytokines based upon these levels and
this cap here basically from low to high
you can see here from blue to red this
is basically the zero point it's right
down the middle a blue is a decrease in
expression red is increase in amount and
what you see here is the ID authors
identified a cluster they called cluster
one it appears to be elevated in
individuals that have the most severe
form of the CLL whereas there are two
other clusters that stand out that
appear to be more associated with
individuals that do not all have the
most severe form of the disease and
again this is not the be-all end-all
study but I believe that this is a
really nice discovery study to outline
where we may start looking for a
commonality and this in this very awful
disease and it may be important to
understand what's the root role of these
cluster one cytokines versus clusters
two and three and as we already know
therapies multiple antibodies are being
used a number of different treatments of
inflammatory and inflammatory diseases
in cancer now so one could imagine that
a study like this is could actually be a
very nice foundation for new approaches
for a disease like chronic illnesses
so let me just go through one last
little bit of this presentation and it's
really to expand what we can do with the
Luminex portfolio and so what I've been
talking about thus far is really how we
can measure a circulating antigen and
this was basically my former manager he
and I when we were working we kind of
coined okay in the serum proteome know
are two major components one is of
course all the inflammatory agents and
chemokines and cell-cell mediators and
the other of course is and auto
antibodies are an area of increasing
importance and auto antibodies in short
and by the way there are a number of
great papers some of our leading experts
in this include Karen Anderson Josh
libéré and these individuals really
leaders but Auto antibodies are
basically IgG molecules that are
basically produced by our own immune
system in response to the increased
presence of a particular protein it can
be a tumor protein another protein may
be upregulated disease but the point is
that as a human idg molecule that is
actually responsive or or bind binds to
the auto antigen so what we've done with
this prototype form that's what this is
on the right-hand side here we've
developed a linux-based platform that
instead of capturing an antigen on the
surface of the bead using the capture
antibody we start buying and mobilizing
the auto energy on the surface of the
bead so now our affinity reagent on the
bead is really the auto antigen or
though the protein and then what we're
doing is we're pulling out of the for
example an IgG molecule that is highly
specific for the operation and then what
we're able to do is detect
that human auto antibody with an anti
human IgG that oh by the way has the
same RPE flora for as we would use in
our classic cytokine profile acids so in
one sense is it's a very similar layout
we're using the same lead-out system
we're just starting out with a core the
core bead has a different affinity agent
and so what we've done is in the past
we've actually tried to demonstrate I
think we've done a nice job of
demonstrating the value of not only
cytokines but also Auto antibodies and
by the way we have a very powerful
microarray platform called proto array
which it's about 23,000 spots almost
10,000 in proteins spotted on the
surface of the bead and that's that's a
great example of a high content
discovery tool for auto antibody
discovery but in this case what we
wanted to do is we wanted to demonstrate
is there power in measuring not only
cytokines but Auto antibodies in a
disease relevant sample subjects such as
lupus
many of you know Rheumatology know that
lupus is a very challenging disease to
study because there are numbered
different readouts people look at at
different profiles but there's no
there's no one gold standard readout to
so what we try to do here is to better
understand the value of looking at
cytokines with Auto antibodies in the
same small one we ran these two
different kits so of course we have our
dirty plug cytokine panel and we have
this other kit we call the proto Plex
autoimmune so basically it's a Luminex
panel that has 19 different known
autoantigens
and what you might notice for people in
the autoimmune field will recognize that
not all of these proteins are limited to
one particular disease some of them have
to do with thyroid autoimmunity
this connective tissue disorder etc so
this is more of a discovery tool it was
more of a proof-of-concept to see if
there's value in measuring these two
together and what we see here is that
this is a great example of looking at a
number of SOE samples as well as healthy
age match controls and this is a study
that was performed by a number of people
in our group and so it's a nice
comprehensive study to show that we were
able to identify a number of cytokines
in fact I'm only showing three for this
example what we're able by identify five
cytokines and nine in the samples from
those suffering with lupus but the
question here is is any one of these
samples of the gold standard to be
measuring well the answer is no I think
that easy
the groupís would be one of those
diseases that would already be confident
and it's a very challenging disease so
what we did is we tried to identify this
matching matrix here basically
identifies true positives true negative
thoughts positive and then false
negative what we did is we started with
ninety-two lupus samples and 85h match
controls and they were well curated
santa so we knew that this came from
individuals that are suffering from
lupus and so we know that these are SLE
positive samples and the age matched
controls we know that they are healthy
and not suffering from the metal and so
what we have here is this matching
nature of showing about 98%
identification of 98% predicted of the
lupus situation however that's five
targets for anyone sorry that number as
possible the output or the outcome was a
little less impressive with just the
auto antibodies by themselves there's
only 80% but actually and this is some
beautiful work from
John and so it's important to note here
if you look at the two datasets together
not just 30 profiles or 19 profiles if
you look at the two together
there's about 98% predictive power with
only add one in one the work that we're
still trying to validate is whether or
not you can then further identify lupus
from other autoimmune disorders the same
kind of such it's a great example of the
power of looking at not just one type of
city or one kind of protein molecule but
expanding the scope especially in the
case of inflammation and autoimmunity
one can imagine again if we go back to
that wire diagram the immune system is a
very complex system and one can imagine
that if you're not only measuring the
cytokine family but also auto antibody
for example is coming out of one may be
casting a wider net the full extent so
this next slide is just a combined if we
mind everybody that we have a wonderful
global field application specialist team
that can help you with the assays that
not only can they provide training and
seminars I'm just like the one that's
being presented today but they can also
cut your applications troubleshooting
and this email address here below will
take you directly to our support team
and they basically funnel out disperse
out the requests to a particularly
dividual we have individuals covering
the globe and so again I mentioned
earlier in the talk that we do have a
nice white paper that really goes into
greater detail than what I was able to
provide today but there's a lot of great
things happening in that space you might
see other the next kits from other
providers but we really do pride
ourselves and process the quality and
our posts in support that you provide to
really go all the way from sample and
answer to give you the best experience
in this slide here is just to kind of
remind everybody of the diverse area I'm
so lonely able to talk about Luminex
multiplexing today but when you think
about profiling protein quant in general
we cover the gamut everything from all
the becoming of proteins and antibodies
we offer didn't even get to mention
super clonal antibodies which are an
amazing product for us not to mention
all the Eliza's we sell again as a tool
builder it's very nice to see me that
were really expanding on again with the
Lumix portfolio as I talked about today
we can not only measure cytokines and
tools but also bodies I believe joining
later today we'll be talking about our
tune
focus insight dominant and then I
believe earlier today we already
presented on our Western workflow it can
now be done in less than four dollars
using our everything from separate
transfer detect with I bond and then
finally I just briefly touched on proto
R a person microgram but the point here
is that we have a lot of great tools and
again the point is that use the right
tools at my time depend on whether
you're doing targeted discovery
validation and so with that I'll open
the line for any questions thank you
very much for your interest hopefully
this is just the first of other
communications we have with those in the
lab space we really look forward to
working with you like I said as a tool
provider one of our greatest joys
provide tools
assays and kits that really delight you
and allow you to make things for those
important discoveries and publish those
discovery
and top-tier journals so all of my
co-workers we really live vicariously
through the success of our customers
could use our tools so we really
appreciate your support we really look
forward to working with you more and
I'll open the lines for any questions
you may have thank you very much thank
you David for bringing us that
informative presentation it is time for
our Q&A I just want to remind our
audience if you'd like to ask a question
just click on the green Q&A button but
if I'm a lower left of your presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on the screen and hit Send
and we do have our first question
already how do you know that the protein
targets in a multiplex essay are not
going to have cross reactivity and give
you false data good question okay great
a great question and in fact I knew that
was probably going to be something
people would ask and I actually have a
slide for that because I I have been
asked that before and when I didn't have
this slide it was very awkward to
explain it because it's a very simple
study a very simple experiment but
trying to explain it without this slide
is one more challenging but basically
what our when our R&D and manufacturing
teams do is this is a great example of a
cytokine 9 flex and what we've done here
is we have each of the bead regions that
are conjugated with an anti let's say
anti
I'll tend antibody aisle 10 I'll 13 etc
and what we're showing here in green is
the specific fluorescence intensity that
comes from measuring that Isleton signal
with an anti Isleton
detection antibody and so one can
imagine that if this Isleton capture be
picked up other things and by the way so
the detection antibodies are a cocktail
right in this case it's a nine Plex so
all nine detection antibodies are all in
one vial and so if if if the aisle 10
capture bead also picked up let's say 13
or aisle four you'd see those signals
line up too because of course the
detection antibody for aisle 4 and 13
they're all in the mixture and the point
here is you see a very nice signal to
noise ratio so again for those that
can't read I'm sorry the slides too
small but this aisle 10 specific signal
is 6780
fluorescence and the background signal
is single digits 8 9 8 8 9 median
fluorescence intensity and so you're
talking 6700 versus nine so that's a
huge fold signal-to-noise and what you
see that is you see that same pattern
all the way down nine targets well this
type of measurement this type of test is
run on all so you can imagine for a 35
Plex we also have the same type of graph
but it covers all 35 it's just I didn't
put it up here because it would go off
the page so but it's a great example of
we just demonstrate there's a specific
signal and again it all depends upon the
high quality antibodies and making sure
that those antibodies don't cross react
with either antigen or other antibodies
and that's a key point to mention here
is that one can you know so you have to
worry about not only antibody antigen
interaction helps answer that question
yes we do have another question and
we're coming up on time this is gonna be
out to be our last question but an
attendee acts are the luminex essays
more sensitive than a licen thank you
great question so it really depends on
the target some of our targets and by
the way this is all readily available in
our in the product insert some of the
targets actually are more sensitive it
really depends upon the target we've
seen some that are actually it's a great
antibody pair but it really depends it's
a target to target you can imagine
though the number of antibodies to
choose from when you're looking at let's
say 35 Plex the most important
specification is to make sure that
there's no cross reactivity whatsoever
and so if we have let's say we 10-week
us ten different antibodies some of them
may actually be more sensitive than a
Wiseman and they could produce a more
sensitive [ __ ] however those
antibodies that are more sensitive may
have cross reactivity characteristics
and we then choose not to use that
antibody even though it might be more
sensitive we would choose not to use an
antibody because we do not want cross
reactivity in Flex panel so it really
depends on the but there are some that
are more sensitive but I would I do want
to say with confidence that they're
there on par um so yeah again it depends
on the analyte
okay thank you for those answers David
we are out of time for our questions I
just want to ask dr. Borden if he has
any final comments or thoughts for our
audience today I know I just want to
first of all thank everyone I guess
later I'll find out how many attended
the talk but you know this is a new
platform for us it's very exciting as as
a scientist leading a group we
definitely I love the interactive nature
of this I hope we can do it more in the
future I hope that some of you hopefully
will be talking to you in the future it
allows us to really get our message
across and we just look forward to
working with all sorts of individuals
working for the best tools in protein
quads so hopefully I'll be speaking to
some of you again in the future but
please feel free to reach out to our
sales force field application
specialists all of them know how to get
a hold of me so if you have any
particular questions but any of us can
help you and we really look forward to
to empowering you thank you too as well
David it's been great having you here
and having you bring this important
information I want to thank also our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2017 you'll be receiving
an email from laberd's alerting us to
when the webcast is available for replay
and we would invite you to share that
email with any colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all we
have for now thank you for joining us
and we hope to see you again